This video is made possible by the free to play action game. Cross out,
check out the game through the link in the description below,
and you can start with three extra weapons or a vehicle cabin just for
registering more on them in a box
In the dying days of the 20th century,
a strange and terrifying plague began to cough a path through Britain.
We're not talking about HIV.
The virus that caused such devastation across the globe in the eighties and
nineties,
we're talking instead about something far more sinister and epidemic
that should never have happened. Bovine spongiform encephalopathy,
better known as BSE or by its nickname. Mad cow disease.
First appeared on a British farm around Christmas, 1984 in no time at all.
It had spread first to herds across the country and then into the human food
chain. The results would be catastrophic starting in 1996,
nearly 240 people would be struck down by variant Creutzfeldt-Jakob disease.
The human form of BRC one by one,
the victim's relatives were forced to watch as the plague devoured their loved
one's minds.
Eventually leaving only a tortured husk fatal in 100% of
cases, its detection was a death sentence rather than occurring. Naturally,
this was a disease with a very human origin.
One only made possible by a terrifying collision of corporate greed government
malfeasance and share callous stupidity.
Today biographics is investigating the story of BRC.
The deadly plague created by men
Where it's most associated with the 1990s.
The story of BSE actually begins a long time ago,
nor does it actually begin with a cow.
Instead it starts on a British farm in 1732 with one on lucky sheep.
Sadly, we don't know enough about what happens at paint you a verbal picture.
We can't open this section with it was a dark and stormy nice or
anything else, suitably autonomous,
but we can say how it must've looked to the farmer.
His long forgotten sheep would have been anxious.
Delirious its head would have jittered from side to side,
making it a pet possessed before long.
It would have become unsteady on its feet.
Started arching its back and scraping and Spalding along stone walls tearing out
its world. Finally, a maximum of six months down the line,
it would have died in agony.
Not long after other sheep would have begun showing signs of the same awful
disease known as scrapey.
The blight eventually affected untold numbers of sheep first across Britain,
and then across most of the rest of the world.
But this being the early 18th century, people were all like,
it's still food and they ate the dead and infected sheep and it didn't
cause many problems to this day.
There's no evidence that scrapey couldn't jump the species barrier.
Unfortunately, this would cause a major issue.
Some 250 years down the line.
When the first cattle started showing signs of BRC in the mid 1980s,
it be because of humanity's experience with scrapey.
This ineffective beef was declared safety eat,
but before we get to that part of our story,
we have to make another pit stop cut to the 1920s. It's the era of jazz.
Everyone's dressed like they're in the great Gatsby and a toothbrush.
Mustache is still in legitimate fashion choice in the shadows though,
a new disease is growing Creutzfeldt-Jakob disease or CJD is a
degenerative brain disease.
That's both super deadly and super rare effecting only one in a million
people.
But what made it extra fascinating for the 1920s doctors was the way it
worked. See the surface of our brains, the covet in proteins called prions.
What CJD does is fold these premiums in a weird way.
These weird folded proteins, then lashed together to form toxic chains.
As these chains grow, break apart and grow again,
they spread across the brain killing cells and leaving sponge-like holes.
But because the proteins are a natural part of us,
our immune system doesn't identify them as something worth attacking,
but someone infected with C J D.
This means a steady decrease in mental functions and motor skills.
There's confusion, anxiety,
and difficulty walking that soon progresses into serious disability within a few
months you'll debt.
And there's no way to stop it since its discovery in the 1920s,
C J D has been with us pretty consistently. Most years,
around 350 Americans die from it,
but it would be events in the 1990s that brought CJD firmly into
the spotlight.
The final piece of setup we need for up story today came around the same time
that C J D was discovered. At some point,
farmers realized they could get more profit from an animal by letting literally
none of it go to waste the grim bits like spinal cord and all the leftovers
could be rendered down,
mulched up and fed back to other animals as feed grosses. The sounds,
it was a major breakthrough animals that consumed the shredded remains of their
brethren tended to grow bigger and faster than others. By the 1980s,
this barnyard cannibalism had spread across the planet,
revolutionizing food production.
Now it was about to cause the biggest food contamination crisis in British
history.
Sure.
Way before Christmas day, 1984, David B got the call that would change his life.
The local vet in his part of Sussex B was famous among his neighbors for his
pleasant singing voice. Soon though,
it'd be known for a very different reason on a farm moons by Peter stent,
a cow was dangerously sick with no one knew when he examined it.
He found the cow had unsteady legs and arched back and ahead.
That was wobbling from side to side.
It wasn't the first in the area to Australia symptoms just recently.
One of B's veterinary friends that told him if a cow that trying to chase them
on legs. So weak that he'd have to run on its knees boss.
This was the first time B had seen this weird new illness op close.
And he didn't like what he saw at all.
The closest thing to the symptoms he could think of was mercury poisoning,
but how the hell would a single get poisons out on a random farm?
So they kept an eye on the animal. And when it died in February, 1985,
he contacted the UK central veterinary laboratory, the CVL. Then on September,
the CVL examines the brain of cow 133 and founds the telltale sponge-like
holes of Creutzfeldt-Jakob disease. They named this new council version,
bovine spongiform encephalopathy or BSC belly had they
identified the illness.
Then it began cropping up everywhere over the next two years,
BSE spread across the South of England.
Six positive cases were confirmed alongside 13 suspected ones in the CVL
discussions done.
So where the scrapey had jumped the species barrier from sheep to cows,
there was even talk about getting more researchers involved,
but the powers that be put a stop to that,
a governmental memo from the time red,
if the disease turned out to be bovine scrapey is going to have a severe
repercussions to the export trade at present,
I would recommend playing it low key. And these two sentences,
you can see the diseased heart of the BSE crisis. It was the 1980s.
Agriculture was a huge part of Britain's economy.
A health scare could cost the country billions.
So officials were incentivized to keep quiet about a potential crisis as 1997
dawned no one said a word.
They kept silent as the number of cases jumped to 46.
That August then 73 than 120, by the end of October,
the first reports were appearing in the farming press about a deadly new cattle
blight. But by then it was too late.
Remember how we said that farm is in the mid 20th century had started feeding
unusable bits of data animal back to that livestock. Well,
they were now doing the same with BSE infected cows,
but no longer was the mulch just going to other cattle.
Mechanically recovered meat is a euphemism for all the gruesome bits of animal
that no one wants to eat in the 1980s,
someone hits on the idea of putting it into human products.
This being the Thatcher era regulation was light. Whiter was all like, Hey,
you want to feed spinal cord to children? Sure. Sounds like fun.
So this mechanically recovered meat made from the most infectious parts of BSC
castle was recycled into sausages into pies and do anything the industry you
could get away with by the time the press started reporting on BSC,
the ship had already sailed.
Gibbons were eating infected meat by the millions and it's nobody had any idea
what would happen next. Now you get into what exactly does happen next.
Let me tell you about today's sponsor cross out,
cross out as a fantastic game where you build your own vehicle and you pick
yourself against other people's vehicles.
Now this isn't one of those games where it's like, yeah,
you get to build a vehicle,
but you just get to choose the type of ammo and maybe what sort of tires go on
your craft. No. And cross out,
you get to build everything from the main structure up.
You can stick on some rail guns at rocket booster.
Some armor runs well without you're ready to fight,
but there's loads of other stuff you can tug on as well.
If you build your craft, well, you're going to dominate. If you build it badly.
Well, you're probably going to get dominated.
It's a super fast paced game with loads of different game modes,
and you've got pretty much limitless freedom to create.
And what you do with your vehicle is entirely up to you.
Also a major plus is that the game's not complicated, right? From the start.
You can just jump in and get going right away without too much trouble.
But there's also lots of skills to build. As you get better at the game,
you already begin to understand this and builds more complex things.
The game grows with you. So join us on the battlefield for free, by the way,
did I mention that the game is free PC Xbox one, PS4 easy.
And if you go through the link below,
you get a free starter set with three extra weapons or a vehicle cabin,
all this,
just a bonus for registering and doing that is a great way to support what we're
doing here at biographics. And.
Let's get back to the video.
1988, 200 new cases of BSE were being reported every week,
effecting 6,000 British farms to the British government's credits.
They did try to act that same year.
The practice of feeding animal remains to other animals was banned.
The following year,
the use of mechanically recovered meat in human foods was outlawed,
but that was where the positive action ended.
More than a million impacted castle were already in the human food chain.
Burgers steak joins of roasting beef, or could be carrying this disease.
The governments had two choices. They either recalled the Meese,
told people to avoid beef and watch the agriculture industry employed,
or they just acted like nothing had happened and just hoped for the best it was
at this point that 1732 reached across the centuries to deliver the presence,
a devastating kick to the testicles. BSE looked like scrapey.
And since scrape had been around since 1732 without infecting humans,
officials assumed BSC would act in exactly the same way.
It was a decision based, not on science,
but assumption on that would turn out to be catastrophically misjudged.
Not that the public would be told this in 1990,
the food and agriculture minister,
John Gummer began a media blitz to get Brits eating beef. Again,
a massive full-page ad vote was taken out in the major papers,
declaring and bowls. Taxed beef is safe on TV.
Gummer repeated the message saying British beef could be eaten by adults and
children without worry at no point did he add, I mean, I guess I seriously,
you guys are just, you know, make it assumptions really, but boldly very,
very boldly.
There is no need for people to be worried. And I can say perfectly honestly,
that I should go on. Each of these children would go on each [inaudible].
No, the talking point was beef is safe.
Anyone who says otherwise is a science hating a Luddite,
not the science itself agreed that same year 1990,
Dr. Steven [inaudible] was conducting some worrying experiments.
He had shown that unlike scrapey BSC could be used to infect mice in
laboratories, but when he tried to speak out,
he was removed from his post and reassigned to a lowly station where he couldn't
conduct further research. Meanwhile, John Gaman took a break from photo ops,
eating steak topped off to go on TV and to cues orange scientists of
scare-mongering looking back now, it's weird. Just how Soviet this all sounds.
The official denials,
the assumptions that politicians know better than scientists that panicked
coverups.
And a lot of ways you could say the BSE scandal was really the West's version of
something like these fed locks, anthrax leaks,
the accidental 1979 release of anthrax spores in Russia that killed a hundred
civilians. In both cases,
the government pretended nothing was wrong in both cases,
nobody ever faced any kind of prosecution.
But while these fed loves disaster would kill a hundred BSE would kill many
more. By the end of the year,
the John Gummer propaganda machine was in overdrive and one uncomfortable
instance. He was photographed feeding his four year old daughter,
a beef burger bumps by now the dangers of BRC were becoming all too apparent
that May,
1990 accounts in Bristol had died from BSC after being fed infected beef.
By the time the year ended 18 more cats were dead from the disease.
This wasn't another scrape.
There was now clear evidence that BSE was not just jumping the species barrier,
but leaping over it with gay abandon,
14 other species had now been infected from household pets to animals in zoos.
Everything that ate beef seems to be coming down with this awful and fatal
illness with one major exception as 1991,
Dawn's bringing with it a new prime minister,
not a single case of BSE in humans had yet been recorded, but sadly,
that was bounced to chain.
[Inaudible].
The start of the crisis. In 1989,
the British government had ordered the extermination of all effected cattle.
However, they offered farmers only 50% compensation for each cow killed.
And in fact,
putting a heavy financial incentive in place for ignoring or misdiagnosing early
signs of BSE. On top of that,
the mechanically recovered meats ban of 1999 had a woeful lack of oversight.
As late as November,
1995 infected spinal column would still be making its way into the human food
supply.
All of which may go some way to explaining what would happen next in May, 1995,
BSE as a national crisis seemed to be on the wane.
The peak days of 1992 to 1993,
when three cattle in every 1000 were infected, had already passed.
Then disaster struck the first symptoms. 19 year old,
Steve Churchill showed hallucinations and trouble walking.
Initially doctors diagnosed him with a psychiatric disorder,
but as time went on and his condition deteriorated,
it became clear that there was something badly wrong at 9:00 AM.
On may the 21st, 1995, Steve Churchill died in the aftermath.
His brain was sent to Edinburgh for analysis that they discovered the telltale
tiny sponge-like holes of creeps, felled Yacob disease in and of itself.
This was not impossible in the mid nineties as now,
natural CJD killed around 60 Britains a year,
but rarely did it attack someone so young by June scientists working on the poor
dead boy's brain were terrified. They might have a new disease on their hands.
That predictions would turn out to be painfully, right?
That October two teenagers came down with this new form of CJD.
Then a casual farmer come March, 1998.
Young people had all died of CJD in a matter of months and in a statistical
impossibility on the eighth of the month,
the government called a meeting with the nation's top scientists.
It was there that a horrifying announcement was made just by all the years of
assurances. Despite John governor's massive propaganda drive BSC, uh,
jumped the species barrier, mad cow disease was now killing humans,
eating away at their brains. There was no way to stop the process or of assets.
And no one knew how many people are infected.
The next few days played out like a horror movie.
As the human form of BSE was declared variant crude so-called Yacob disease,
or the CJD panics politicians asked how many people it might kill.
The answer was anything from a few hundred to over half a million,
half a million Britons killed by a disease.
There was entirely manmade disease that wouldn't exist.
If the government hadn't stifled scientists and made faulty assumptions, yet,
even as those in white, all face down the barrel of a devastating pandemic,
no one bothered to warn the public.
No one told people about the dangers of eating beef for another 12 days.
Finally, on the morning of March the 20th, 1996,
the tabloid the daily mirror broke the story in bold text.
BSC can kill humans just hours later.
The health secretary stood up before parliament and declared a new deadly brain
disease caused by infected beef had been discovered by now the attended cases in
humans, what happens next? No one knew they could. However, agree on one thing,
it was going to be the scandal of the decade.
The mouth of the government's announcement Britain's beef industry collapsed
billions of pounds were wiped out alongside millions of cattle in an effort to
control the disease. 4.4 million cows were slotted and burned.
Incinerators glows on farms around the clock.
Dead cattle piled up in mountains of corpses out to 60 farms,
went bankrupt internationally.
The EU immediately banned all beef and bolts from Britain.
It was already too late. Over the following years, 26 French people would die.
A V C J D alongside five Spaniards, four Irish, three Dutch, two Italians,
and two Portuguese.
But it was in Britain that the human cost would be at its highest. By 1998,
there were 18 cases a year. All of them fatal. Well,
that's a relatively small number, mosques, awful suffering,
almost all of the victims of V C J D one under 30. Most were teenagers.
As the disease took hold, they lost their motor functions.
The ability to speak became badly disabled, unable to do anything.
But when in pain, as their families looked on helpless to stop their agony,
it was a nasty, painful way to die.
One made worse by different approaches across the nation. In some areas,
patients were allowed to be with their families in others.
They were locked in isolation for the last months of their lives left to die
alone in agony, by local authorities,
scared they might pass their sickness on that same year,
the new government set up a research body to basically try and estimate how
screwed they were.
The answer utterly VC JD was found to not just in fact,
the brain ends the spine. It infected the entire body,
even getting into the blood. And some of those who had already died,
a VCG D were known blood donors over 6,000 people in Britain were given BSE
infected blood.
As the government spends a hundred million pounds to filter the disease out of
the blood bank. Most countries on earth, BAMS,
British blood donations bands that still remain in effect as the new millennium
dawns.
It looks like the crisis would never end the year two thousands or a jump in
annual deaths to 28. The next year BSC appeared in Japanese cattle.
The first country outside Britain to be sucked into the crisis.
Two years after that in 2003 Canadian cattle were infected,
at least one enter the human food chain leading to a total shutdown of Canadian
exports. That's wiped $11 million off the economy every single day.
And then just as it looked as if the crisis had hit a tipping point, it stopped.
Although 2005 saw the first Japanese human death from VC J D.
It wouldn't be followed by another. In the UK.
The cases were on a downward trends by 2007.
It dropped to only five cases per annum,
although over 160 persons that died so far,
it seems like the threats of death from mad cow disease had it lost faded.
[Inaudible].
In the mid 1950s,
scientists made a gruesome discovery in the Highlands of new Guinea and isolated
tribe was being filled by something similar to crude smell to Yacob disease,
children, adults, the elderly were also coming first, losing their coordination,
then feeling their mind, slip away as the blade consumed them.
Given the rarity of CGD,
it would have been remarkable if two members of the tribe had died of it,
but dozens, clearly something was going on.
So scientists investigated and uncovered a shocking story.
The tribe were cannibals whose death rituals involve eating the bodies of their
loved ones at some points that consumed the brain of someone with CJD,
allowing it to infect more tribe members who in turn infected more tribe members
when the diet of the disease. So on,
it was eerily similar to BSE in Britain so much so that when the mad counters
these get kicked off in the 1990s, London sent some people to investigate.
They would not return with reassuring news, just like with the CJD,
the new Guinea tribe that exhibited an onset of symptoms some five years after
eating infected meat. But there hadn't just been a single spate of deaths.
There had been at least two distinct waves. In some cases,
the incubation period, it lasted up to 50 years,
the proteins that CGD deforms.
Remember the ones that turn into toxic chains that eat through your brain.
They always carry one of two variants and or V since they're
inherited from our parents, everyone on earth has either,
mm genes in these proteins or MV or VV all the new Guinea tribe members to
die in. The first wave had the M M genotype. Now nearly half a century later,
all those to die from V C J D in Britain and abroad had also been, mm, types.
This left a single horrifying likelihood BSC was going to
return. And it started in late 2014,
a 36 year old British man began showing signs of CJD.
When he died in February, 2016,
scientists checked his brain and discovered had been infected with the human
form of BSE, likely from eating infected meat as a child. But here's the kicker.
When scientists finally checked his genotype,
they found he didn't hold an mm combination, but MV,
there had been a suspected case before in 2009,
but this was the first confirmed one. Finally,
the dormant disease was activating in a whole new slew of people.
And with that cliffhanger, our story has to end since 2016,
there have been no more confirmed deaths of MV gene holders due to the CJD.
It may be that this manmade plague is over that there will be no more deaths and
mad cow disease will soon be seen as a Relic of the 1990s on par with the spice
girls and maybe got cheese. But that seems unlikely.
Everything we know about VCG D suggests there's a second wave right around the
corner, uh,
points in the near future when it will cut a swath through Britain's population.
Again, felling those with the VMG genotype in the early 2000 and tens,
the UK government reported that as many as one in 2000 Britains may be silent
carriers, a VCG D with dozens, more scattered across the globe.
When the second wave finally hits,
it could kill any number of them to date 178.
People in the UK have died of human variant BSC with another 52 dads and other
countries in a world shaken by COVID-19.
It's tempting to hear such statistics and think that's not much,
but make no mistake. VC J D isn't a regular disease.
It's a man-made disaster and a government coverup,
one more comparable to Soviet bio weapons leak,
or the Tuskegee syphilis experiments than to a natural phenomenon faced with
knowledge that could have saved lives if published,
but resulted in an economic hit.
The British government chose to protect the economy because of that choice.
Over 230 people died with hundreds, more possibly to come.
Usually when we think of these sorts of coverups,
we think of incompetent dictatorships. So nations in the distant past,
but BSE a disease caused by human greed shows this isn't always the case.
You can live in a rich Western functioning democracy and still be
killed by government malfeasance.
The story of this horrific plague isn't over there may be another volume,
still waiting to be written.
One that catalogs yet more deaths yet more appalling,
needless suffering. All we can do is just wait and see.
So I'm not going to ask if you enjoyed that video,
but I do hope you found it interesting. If you did,
please do hit that like button below.
Don't forget to subscribe and please do check it off.
Fantastic sponsors across out.
Thank you for watching.